[Music]
so terrorism is back
as a big issue and president macron in
many ways has been giving a lead on this
he is not one for uh
mincing his words when it comes to
dealing with
islamist terrorism its
cause of some international problems
with the turks and with other parts of
the middle east
as well but he has taken a strong clear
line on this
even as there have been more attacks on
the street it is the subject
of our spectator magazine cover story
this week is written by our associate
editor douglas
murray and douglas uh it's a great cover
story it's a
a great piece to go with it
but your main angle is that mr macron
is kind of on his own on this the the
the other western leaders
they might agree with them but they're
just keeping their heads down
yes that's right uh we ran a piece in
the spectator last month immediately
after mr macron's speech a lot of
publications missed it
there's not been any shortage of news
recently um but of course we
recognized the the this speech and diane
herciale wrote for us about
what an important speech it was of
course those people who'd been
criticizing president macron for even
making the speech
ended up on the back foot only days
afterwards when we saw the murder
of mr patty the french school teacher
in the days and weeks since we've seen a
pattern of events which sadly as you
know is
is not unfamiliar in france now uh the
fact that
an attack that began with the french
school teacher being killed for
certain secular french values was then
followed up with an attack on three
worshipers coming out of a
church service is something of course
that france has seen before an attack on
everything from the secular tradition
to the right of freedom of worship but
what is so striking about it
two things one are the attacks on the
french republic
not just on president macron but on the
nature of the french republic
from people vying in the international
arena to be the effectively leader of
the world's muslims
but prime principally prime minister
imran khan in pakistan but more
significantly
the turkish president erdogan that's the
first most interesting thing but the
second most interesting thing as you say
is the fact that the allies the
erstwhile allies
the closest allies of france seem to
have been so silent
on supporting their ally in this
particular issue
you know we have seen justin trudeau
actually take a view that seems to
suggest that there's some kind of moral
equivalence on the one hand french
secularism
on the other hand uh um you know uh
uh tolerance and and and more
and so that's one type of reaction
that's come and the other
has been effectively silence
where is the german government when
the french government and indeed state
is being delegitimized across the world
where is the british government where
are the allies of france across our
continent and
and the answer to that seems to be
absolutely nowhere
president macron has been remarkably
robust
in the brexit negotiations his attitude
towards
fishing rights is one of the stumbling
blocks
did our own prime minister not miss an
opportunity here he could have stood
four
square with president macron on this and
almost
implicitly embarrassed president macron
into
backing off a bit on the fishing rights
thing while
doing the right thing while our prime
minister would have done the right thing
to have stood by mr macron he
missed that yes yes that's right he
absolutely missed the opportunity to
assert our um solidarity on the most
fundamental level
i think by the way uh there are several
explanations
you give the first most generous one is
there's an awful lot going on at the
moment in downing street
uh that they're simply unable and this
isn't by any means to let them off the
hook but simply unable to
uh juggle the number of things that are
coming on that could be one explanation
but another which i sense is going on
internationally
is that uh france is coming under
significant pressure you know
there are large countries now some of
which i just mentioned you know calling
for the usual things boycotts of french
goods
uh demonizing the whole state not just
not just the current government though
the current president but the whole
foundation of the state
in france um in that situation it seems
to me that there has
arisen in our time a certain tendency of
other european and western states to try
to duck
the whirlwind to sort of hope that the
whirlwind passes over their house
we saw something similar in 2005 and six
with the danish cartoons controversy
even other scandinavian countries wanted
to slightly step away from denmark
they didn't want to be in the same
boycotts as denmark was already in
and i think this is an enormous shame
and a missed opportunity as well as
a missed opportunity to assert a
principle of solidarity across
the free world i guess what i'm saying
douglas is that because the president
has put the very soul of the republic
at the heart of this not saying that
muslims are in any way incompatible with
republican french values but the the
islamist view of the world is
definitely incompatible with it that's a
pretty big battle he's taking on that
yes of course he's not the first french
leader to take on that battle uh um
uh emmanuel vales when he was prime
minister recently in france took on
the same battle asserted some of exactly
the same principles that mr macron has
what's interesting about it this time is
that macro appears to be acting and not
just
talking uh a a few weeks ago ion hersey
ali in the magazine was rightly
skeptical about whether this would just
be more words from the french president
but in the weeks since then we have seen
a number of actions
uh the withdrawal of the french
ambassador to turkey quite rightly after
the outrageous
um misrepresentation of the french
president's remarks
by president edwan in turkey
calls uh by the french for further
strictures against the turkish
government including
uh being cast out of the trade
cooperation agreements that it has with
the eu and then there has been
other progre um progressive developments
including the closure
of the bank accounts indeed the banning
of certain extremist groups in france
and then most remarkably in some ways
the french president's
uh call for an indeed ordering of a
doubling of french border forces
and then his assertion of two things in
particular one
he says that when he comes to the
european council meeting
in december he will be calling for first
of all
a rethink of the schengen
agreements which allow the free movement
of course of people across borders once
they are in europe and secondly
a strengthening of external borders this
must be on his mind in particular
because
of the um of the fact that the attacker
in nice who has been detained for
killing three people outside the church
uh is a young tunisian man who entered
europe in september through the italian
island of lampedusa which i reported
from for the spectator
in 2015-26 for years people have been
able to tell european leaders and have
said
if you don't if you have an entirely
porous external border
and free movement within the borders of
europe
this is a security nightmare that will
keep on
emerging now previously it has been
principally central european eastern
european leaders who have made that
point
in recent days there's been another
flare-up of tension between chancellor
merkel and her counterpart in austria
the the austrian chancellor sebastian
kurtz over exactly this issue
but to have uh uh that fight in the past
tended to be a sort of east europe
versus west europe point
to have emmanuel macron
saying the same things that are being
said in central and eastern europe
indeed in mediterranean europe
is a very significant development and it
leaves effectively
chancellor merkel alone
what do you say final question douglas
to to
the most cynical point which is it's
just all politics
that uh the center right in france is on
its back
the center left is untears the socialist
parties do not manage to rebuild itself
the mr melenchon runs the left he's
never going to get very far
mr macron has concluded that the only
real threat to his re-election is marine
le pen
and he's moved his tanks onto her lawns
there is a possibility it's it's it's
it's politics as usual
uh of course as you know in the last uh
presidential election in france in some
ways it was a sort of
fluke or at least a very small
percentage chance that meant
that uh that macro and le pen went
through
as they did because the the vote was
effectively split
uh in quarters in france and
uh the the calibration that macro
macro is making could just as easily if
it was totally cynical go the other way
in some ways
um it's true he needs to take some of
those le pen votes but he needs to take
votes from a number of directions uh i
myself
think that you know one can't read into
the hearts of politicians
uh what we can do is judge their words
and judge whether they act on their
words
and that is what makes this particular
episode unusual
it's not just being words that are
actually actions you know
um calling for diplomatic sense against
the turkish government for its
outrageous colonies against the french
republic
is a stepping up uh er
actually closing groups not just talking
about closing uh
groups that teach extremism and
encourage extremism but actually closing
them
is not just words its actions so perhaps
this is some kind of corner i'm very
skeptical as you know of the
tendency to look for tipping points and
inflection points but in the long battle
of the french republic against islamic
extremism
what we're going through at the moment
is definitely some form of progress
[Music]
you